salut si je commence la vidéo semble que
nous ayons ça marchera pas c'est mieux
comme ça quoique là vous envoyer qu'un
petit bout double là on en voit beaucoup
mais c'est un peu le bordel je pense que
là c'est pas mal comment ça va comment
est ce que vous allez aujourd'hui
j'espère que ça va on va se parler paix
c'est pourquoi parce que huawei m'a dit
tiens monsieur grenat deux nouveaux pc
on aimerait bien que tu puisses les
présenter j'aime bien les pc de voir oui
j'aime bien ce qu'ils proposent un
bateau que c'est d'ailleurs merci à vous
de m'avoir offert ce joli petit truc là
la sas et ses griffes à mon nom regardez
ce mois ci aurélie l'écrit youri as
écrit en tout petit c'est très compliqué
de le voir donc voilà c'est qu'il y
aurait là ça fait plaisir aujourd'hui on
présente 2 pc on présente celui là alors
celui là c'est tout premier pc celui-là
c'est le macbook 16 s my book 16s cayla
qui est beau qu'il faut aller voir est
très différent par rapport au 2ème que
je vous présentais c'est le macbook des
16 on a 2 pc 7 pouces on a surtout 2 pc
qui sont assez légers ça c'est plutôt
bien là de ces secousses qui sont quand
même relativement différent et c'est ça
qui va être super intéressant
aujourd'hui alors un an toute chose on
sunshine
en termes de poids et tout et tout de
suite les deux se valent on a un coût 99
on a un kilo 79 on a 2 pc qui sont quand
même relativement les idées très cool la
première grosse différence aussi de
faire un peu de place nette on va se
mettre sur le 16 aces le css regardez on
va le prendre on va l'ouvrir tact
première chose vous posez votre doigt up
la cape town empreintes digitales
salivaire ou très rapidement c'est
valable pour les deux donc ça c'est
plutôt bien est ce une techno qu'un peu
standard mais qui va très bien et fait
toujours plaisir premier truc c'est
qu'ici vous avez une dalle brillante une
dalle brillante et une dalle surtout qui
va être complètement tactile à la
différence au plat de son petit copain
le décès zilla le capteur d'empreintes
digitales également mais par contre lui
il pas tactile et une dalle mate ça
c'est le premier point de différence et
puis un deuxième poids qui est
extrêmement important qui se pensent
faire la différence qui fera que vous
allez allez sur l'un ou plutôt sur
l'autre regardez déjà celui là comme ça
je trouve hyper canon je sais c'est
vraiment le celui que je vais préférer
cette sagesse mois avec cet écran qui
n'est pas mal de bons qui va réfléchir
davantage par rapport à l'autre vous
voyez on verra tout de suite un petit
peu moins regardés on voit un peu mon
t-shirt là qui se réfléchit l'autre côté
on l'a pas du tout mais je suis quand
même préféré celui là alors regardez ce
qui est super intéressant dans cette
vraie différence que vous avez entre les
deux c'est que celui là sur le macbook
16s vous avez un écran 3 2 me c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est du 16/9 mais un
peu plus le 16/9 s'arrête par là vous en
avez un peu plus pour votre argent la
différence du 2 me qu'on va avoir ici le
des 16 c'est qu'en fait le décès ce
n'est sur une résolution
16/10 il va être beaucoup plus allongée
donc en fait sur le macbook 16s on va
avoir un écran qui va être un peu plus
grand qu'un 16/9 et sur l'autre on est
un peu plus allants girons le voit
vraiment la voit la différence comme ça
au delà en plus du côté matt où vous
n'avez pas de reflet donc c'est vraiment
à vous de me dire ce que vous préférez
passer quand même une vraie différence
entre les deux dans les deux cas vous
êtes sur une dalle ipes c'est du lcd
dans les deux cas c'est du 16 pouces
dans les deux cas vous avez un ratio
châssis écran 90% dans les deux cas vous
avez 310 maximum de luminosité dans les
deux cas très tordu 100% srgb ici sur le
cs vous êtes sur une résolution 2.54 cdu
2520 par 1680 pixels parce que l'autre
côté vous êtes sur du full hd donc et
aussi une différence en termes de
résolution ça dépend ce que vous voulez
en faire ici vous voyez il ya quand même
une vraie différence entre ces deux pc
dont la première question à se poser
c'est est-ce que je veux une dalle mate
ce que je veux une dalle brillante est
ce que je veux une résolution un peu
plus élevées pour venir faire de la
retouche photo pour venir faire un peu
de montage vidéo un peu parce que vous
allez barque bien qu'on ait de la
performance en termes de cartes
graphiques c'est pato que plus le plus
fou fou non plus donc voilà ça c'est
vraiment un choix à faire si vous êtes
plus créateur plus secrète si vous
voulez faire de l'édition voulait faire
de l'infographie voit aujourd'hui dessin
je vous conseille d'aller sur le macbook
16s si maintenant vous voulez un
ordinateur un peu moins cher mais tout
autant performant et vous allez voir je
vous en présente quelques instants avec
une dalle mate et avec un très bel écran
16 10ème et bien vous pouvez aller sur
le macbook décès ce qui est très cool
voyais on a un peu de style différent
sur les csp ça c'est vachement bien tout
en sachant que ce sont des écrans qui
sont certifiés lutter contre les
lumières bleues certification tuv
rheinland et les deux sont anti centimes
donc on a ce qu'il faut pour venir
protéger vos yeux chose qu'il faut venir
savoir et qui est super intéressante
c'est ce que vous allez me retrouver ici
sous le capot d'un côté et l'autre en
terme de performance alors regarder si
vous venez voir ici sur le macbook 16
aces et bien j'ai un intel i7 certifié
évoquant disque de l'autre côté si vous
regardez sur le macbook des 16 jeunes
intel core i7 mais j'ai pas de
certification et vont donc à une petite
différence entre les deux les
processeurs sont les mêmes ça veut dire
que je suis en intel core de deuxième
génération tu en reçois du i 5 soit du
i7 soit du 19 et une différence au
niveau 2005 c'est vraiment envoyé dans
le détail sur le macbook 16s vous êtes
sur un i5 c1 2005 sans acheter ce sont
mes boucles des seize vous êtes sur un
12450 h et un peu la différence de rêve
sinon les i7 c'est du 12 1700 h et les
neuf cdu 12900 h d'un côté comme de
l'autre donc c'est effectivement des
gènes tout en sachant qu ici là et ça
c'est sur l'huile à la regarder sur mon
netbook 16s je vais avoir 16 giga de ram
c'est la lpddr2 5 et je vais avoir soit
512 soit 1 tera de stockage ont élevé me
paie ses yeux donc ça c'est cool mais la
différence que vous allez retrouver ici
par contre sur celui-là ses classes sur
le 17 juin voire soit 8 soit 16 giga de
ram et je vais avoir uniquement 512 giga
de stockage la même manière en nvm epc
yeux voilà ça il faut le savoir et si
j'ai une italie riz 6 et autant vous
dire que côté graphique c'est pas le
truc le plus fou donc on peut venir
faire un peu de montage si on souhaite
voyez si vous me prenez une grosse
config soit un i7 sont à une heure et
vous mettez un peu de ram derrière avec
16 giga de ram vous ferai de la vidéo
vous ferez du montage vidéo mais on va
pas aller le plus loin ici par rapport à
tout ce qu'on pourrait faire avec des
configs un peu plus performants droit
qu'on a des matches qui sont quand même
fait pour les créatifs je vous le dis je
vous le redis une fois de plus le
macbook 16s vous êtes créatif voulait
faire de la retouche vidéo ou les faire
du dessin vous est infographiste vous
voulez faire de la retouche photo avec
photoshop avec lightroom vous allez sur
ce lien il n'y a pas de souci si vous
êtes plus productivité bureautique
vous allez sur le macbook décès ce qui
est aussi très chouette alors après il y
aussi une différence à venir connaître
ici c'est la différence du côté de la
batterie eh ouais fatalement sur celui
là le csv tournée et pc comme s'avoue un
peu pour s'amuser comme ça pendant deux
heures j'ai une batterie de 84 water
avec une recharge sera forcément plus
rapide que l'autre j'ai de la 90 watts
voyez c'est écrit noir sur blanc tandis
que seul m book des 16 g une batterie de
60 watts heure et une recharge qui va
être un peu moins rapide de 65 watts
donc on voyait donc il ya aussi un choix
qui a été fait en termes de batteries en
termes de capacité de batterie d'un
autre côté sur le macbook 16 aces et
bien il ya un écran de qu'une plus
grosse résolution remirent lui envoyer
un peu un peu plus de patate derrière
voilà pour la différence autre
différence qu'il faut venir connaître
c'est la différence au niveau des
connectiques alors regardez moi ça là on
est sur le macbook 16s je vais déjà
avoir de ce côté là deux usb à 3.2 et de
l'autre côté c'est là où on a un petit
peu plus je vais retrouver deux usb
c'est celle là par contre elle et
thunderball 4 celle ci elle ne l'est pas
les deux sont display port et puis je
peux bien faire mais transfère données
facilement ici j'ai une prise hdmi et
une prise jack qui me servira aussi bien
pour le micro que pour le casque pour
micro casque comme vous voulez tandis
que sur mon macbook et 16 eh bien je
vais retrouver de ce côté là de la même
manière deux prises usb sauf que j'ai
une usb 2.0 et usb 3.2 pour le savoir de
l'autre côté j'ai deux usb c'est celle
ci servira pour la charge celle là ne
servira pas pour la charge faut le
savoir également sans coup on va se dire
qu'on n'arrive pas à charge et non en
revanche est là pour charger un hdmi de
la même manière et une petite prise jack
micro jack de la même manière alors dans
les deux cas c'est plutôt cool la
différence si on le voit une fois de
plus pour le côté créateurs peu le côté
créatif on va se diriger sur le macbook
16s pourquoi et bien parce que vous avez
dû thunderball caté en termes de
transfert et si et ça c'est quand même
vachement mieux voudrais qu'on parle un
peu des claviers parce que là aussi une
très grosse différence alors attention
ici vous voyez un clavier qwerty ne vous
trompez pas c'est juste parce que mon
modèle à moi et encore c'est d'ailleurs
c'est pas un clavier américains parce
que aux us vous avez passé petite touche
là je sais pas si on est norvégien je
sais pas d'où vous venez ici mais en
tout cas ici on est sur un bon vieux
qwerty alors vous aurez un clavier
azerty soyez tranquilles soit les
assurés qu'il faut vraiment venir savoir
et cissé sur le macbook 16s vous avez un
truc un peu standard au niveau de votre
clavier on va voir une course au niveau
du de la frappe qui va être un peu plus
long c'est très confortable je trouve
vraiment très sympa ce clavier puisque
je vous parle du clavier je vous parle
du trackpad en même temps que je trouve
également hyper hyper agréable enfin si
c'est pas de la petit cas ici c'est
vraiment un trackpad veut pas dire à
l'ancienne mais bon track pas de
standards et ça ira très bien ça c'est
pour votre trackpad et puis alors la
différence que vous allez venir
retrouver que le macbook des 16 es là
c'est ça c'est plutôt intéressant si
pour la bureautique c'est qu'en plus ici
vous avez un pavé numérique qui nous ont
un peu compris mais l'histoire dans le
châssis mais pour autant c'est vachement
bien comme il est un poil plus large
voyez les prends je les pose l'un sur
l'autre alors c'est vraiment du point de
détail à mes mom and book en fait vous
ne verrez peut-être pas bien comme ça il
est un petit peu plus large le des seize
j'ai ça en fait sur le côté même si avec
les perspectives vous voyez pas trop
j'ai un peu plus de largeur et cette
largeur à me permet de venir mettre un
clavier un peu plus grands alors si vous
voulez vraiment un clavier pour de la
bureautique vous allez sur le macbook
des seize une fois de plus sans aucun
problème c'est vraiment excellent pc
pour la bureautique je trouve vraiment
top parce que vous avez effectivement et
bien grand clavier azerty très pratique
vous avez en plus ce pavé numérique avec
des petites touches en plus vous allez
avoir la recherche intelligente un petit
raccourci pour la calculatrice pour la
bureautique c'est toujours extrêmement
pratique ou lire désactiver ici votre
webcam ou pas donc ça c'est vachement
cool de la même manière on a une course
de frappe qui est super super agréable
un peu plus longue et très très bien et
puis vous avez votre trek pas de qui est
légèrement sur le côté légèrement par
rapport à ici vaut ici on regarde le
coin avec une voie routière on est un
peu sur le côté mais très honnêtement on
est centrée par rapport aux claviers
principal donc là ça me va bien et en
termes de confort de frappe je trouve
qu'on a ici aussi de la chine qui est
très cool autre différence à connaître
entre ces deux ordinateurs vous avez une
vraie différence en vrai une différence
au niveau du sont donc ça dépend ce que
vous voulez je vous montre regardez sur
le macbook 16s vous avez vos
haut-parleurs qui sont situées juste là
sur le macbook des seize vous avez les
haut parleurs qui sont en dessous la
différence que vous allez retrouver au
niveau du macbook cs leçon va être un
peu plus l'âge
donc ça voyez c'était en un son un peu
plus graves le son est bien mieux parce
que directive vers vous les haut
parleurs concerne vraiment très très
bien je me mets sur le macbook décès
c'est un peu différent voyez je suis à
fond
j'ai un peu moins de volume sonore
et je suis un peu plus médium donc si je
veux aussi une très bonne expérience et
la meilleure expérience de se retrouver
ici au niveau des hauts parleurs au
niveau du son je vais sur le macbook 16s
n'y a pas photo sans problème je vais là
dessus de l'autre côté ça fonctionnera
bien moins une fois de plus dans l'idée
de la bureautique donc on va être un peu
moins exigeants du côté audio tout en
sachant que tu retrouvé deux micros sont
medoukh 16 aces pour tout ce qui va être
visio pour venir discuter échanger de ce
coin côté j'en ai quatre donc ont une
fois de plus dans l'idée de la
bureautique on va avoir quatre micros
pour optimiser l'expérience lorsque vous
allez venir converser avec des collègues
essayer ça autre point qui est aussi
intéressant avec nous a fait voir où on
va sur les deux machines c'est que la
webcam elle se trouve en haut alors à
une époque il nous mettait les webcams
dans le cloud et ce qui était bien parce
qu'en terme de confidences et et c'était
cool mais par contre le truc était un
peu moins cool c'est que vous été filmé
en contre-plongée qu'on voyait tout au
niveau des pôles de vote n'est donc ce
n'est pas dingue tandis que là
maintenant les webcams voyait elle se
trouve ici alors ils ont fait un peu
comme tout le monde ils sont venus les
métros mais c'est quand même vachement
mieux et en plus de ça est ce qui est
pas mal c'est que j'ai deux webcams en
1080p que ce soit sur un pc ou sur l'eau
donc là voyage ne baissions le 16è ce
coucou je suis en 1080p alors je suis
plus en contre-plongée on va plus tout
le groupe est comme ça mais ça m'arrange
suis beaucoup mieux comme ça donc la
voyez c'est quand même vachement cool et
là sur le décès de la même manière j'ai
ma webcam en 1080p sa cause alors cessez
vos qu'amazon truc que nous a fait
huawei qui est vachement intéressant
c'est à dire qu'ils ont fait pas mal de
petites choses d'un point de vue
logiciel d'un point de vue intelligence
artificielle pour retrouver notamment
sur une pour des logiciels de
vidéoconférence à dire que lorsque vous
allez venir regarder la personne en face
de vous on va me regardez pas l'écran
est bien lui il va faire quoi up va
faire comme si vous regardiez tout le
temps la webcam ce qui fait que c'est
plus intéressant pour la personne en
face de vous c'est d'un point de vue
logiciel que ça c'est ça c'est vachement
bien vous avez aussi un floutage de
l'arrière plan qui peut se faire
directement grâce à votre pc donc ça
c'est cool puis vous avez la folle ocam
la faune locale c'est quoi une webcam
qui va me suivre en fonction de mes
déplacements donc si je suis par exemple
dans une vidéo-conférence alors je bouge
je vais pas non plus à l'autre bout de
la pièce mais voyez je bouge je me
rapproche comme ça et bien la faune
locale reste pointé sur moi et ça c'est
vachement bien parce que lorsque vous
faites de la conférence avec des
collègues que vous vous déplacez et bien
comme ça elle va être sur vous elle va
vous suivre et ça c'est vachement
intéressant surtout pour des gens comme
moi quand tout le temps la bougeotte ne
voyait comme ça on est suivie d'un côté
de l'autre on joue au monde et où l'on a
l'impression de voyager ça c'est
vachement cool et en plus de ça il ya de
la suppression de bruit ici directement
avec des micros dans votre pc qui vont
venir supprimer les bruits comme ça on
est sur l'audio l'ordinateur pour vous
puissiez vous rendre compte du site pas
faire trop de bruit il ya un petit bruit
de fond derrière quand même on entend et
à de la rue il ya de la vie est ce que
ça vient faire ici ça vient réduire les
bruits pour vraiment venir se concentrer
sur ce qui sort votre bouche on se
retrouve avec du windows onze familles
alors windows je vous en ai déjà parlé
ou windows on se tournait déjà parlé je
vous invite à revenir voir la vidéo si
vous voulez connaître après les
nouveautés les différences par rapport à
windows dit ce qu'on avait à vanpoulle
on a pas mal de petites choses qui sont
différentes donc windows onze familles
d'un côté comme de l'autre et entre
messieurs double système de ventilation
et des pales plus fine alors je sais
plus combien de palier je vais vous le
dire 79 pâle beaucoup plus fine pour le
refroidissement de votre machine et pour
la dissipation thermique alors l on fait
autre chose aussi par dissipation
thermique c'est à dire que regarder la
voyez il est un peu surélevé ici est
surélevé en bas ce qui fait que ça
permet à l'air de circuler d'un côté
l'autre également ici d'un côté et de
l'autre dans des pareilles ici de la
même manière ici là et là c'est pas des
machines qu'on a cherché au plafond
parce qu'on n'est pas sur des machines
qui sont faites pour du gaming vous
n'allez pas faire des jeux alors si des
petits jeux certes mais pas des jeux
très performant parce qu'on n'a pas
vraiment de grosses cartes graphiques
derrière on est 100 trucs un peu
standard pour que je vous le dis une
fois de plus pour les usages standard
bureautique et un peu de créatifs ici
même beaucoup de créatifs sans vouloir
en faire trop parce qu'on n'a pas une
énorme carte graphique est bien on a de
quoi venir s'amuser après les petites
différences aussi ici sur le macbook cs
vous avez du bluetooth 5.2 sur un
macbook des seize d'ubuntu 5.1 du wifi
si ce soit votre netbook cs je dirais
que l'intérêt de ces produits là c'est
de venir les connecter à tout
l'écosystème huawei alors que ce soit un
écran géant est view qui est juste à
côté ici dont je vous ai déjà parlé vous
pouvez venir l'utiliser comme second
écran ou alors pour venir faire une
copie de votre écran plat vide à venir
voir la vidéo que je vous ai déjà
présenté j'ai déjà montré ses moniteurs
d'ovins qui sont très cools pouvez
également utiliser votre n'est pas de
votre tablette comme deuxième écran en
complément de votre écran d'ordinateur
et yéo ces petites choses là sont les
freebox prod2 qui ont été conçus en
partenariat avec des violets et qui ont
la réguler sans bruit active alors je
vais vous montrer parce que je ne sais
pas atterré et vous allez voir que c'est
extrêmement simple et l'expérience allé
très très cool justement derrière je
déverrouille je prends mes freebox n'est
pas encore ouvert donc l'idée c'est que
j'ai un petit buzz que je peux prendre
avec que je peux venir bien évidemment
mais tribaux hop là je les prends je les
mets dans les oreilles et je n'ai plus
qu'à écouter me connecter en bluetooth
directement je vous ai dit bluetooth 5.2
bluetooth 5.1 de l'autre côté donc enfin
je profite d'une superbe expérience
c'est tout l'idée de l'écosystème de la
même manière je prendre mon ap50 mais 50
pro je vais pouvoir venir le connecter
directement grâce à huawei cher
transférer des photos transférer des
images d'un appareil à l'autre très
facilement pour que tout cette option
d'écosystèmes qui est super intéressant
et même ils vont beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui s'appelle super device vous
venez connecter vos appareils
directement ils se reconnaissent les ans
avec les autres ça permet effectivement
d'avoir l'écosystème très complet et
très simple à venir utiliser donc ça
c'est très chouette alors je vais vous
parler tarek parce que je n'ai pas
encore parlé attention la feuille armes
sur le macbook 16s c'est celui là j'ai
une config aller jeter un coup d'oeil
sur le site de wayne dont une super
config avec un i7 avec 16 giga de ram et
1 tera de stockage vous êtes à 1699 99
il ya des offres tout de suite avec des
cadeaux à l'extérieur cliquez sur le
lien en bas dans la description des
avancées très très cool et si je vais
sur le macbook des 16 c'est celui là qui
est juste là tu voir deux conflits
gossip super cool la première qu'on est
vraiment d'être dans la bureautique un
bureautique pure simple vous êtes à
moins de 1000 euros sur un hit 5 sur 16
giga de ram et 512 giga de stockage de
la
999 euros et si vous voulez monter un
petit peu la config avec un peu plus de
performance / i7 16 giga de ram est
toujours à 112 il ya de stockage parce
qu'il ne peut pas monter au delà on est
à mille 299.99 voilà il ya une fois de
plus des offres allez jeter un coup
d'oeil directement sur le site de huawei
jouer le lien en bas dans la description
donc voyez pour ses machines moi je les
trouve super intéressante j'ai un vrai
coup de coeur sur le macbook 16s j'aime
beaucoup cet écran 3,2 mist écran
brillant à écran tactile j'aime beaucoup
l'idée effectivement et bien d'avoir un
mets haut parleurs en façade il ya de la
performance d'un côté et 2 si vous êtes
plus moi je suis créatif donc j'avais
effectivement avoir ce côté là je
préfère l'écran que je veux retrouver
ici on y re faire de la retouche photo
pour nous refaire un peu de montage si
maintenant vous en fichez de ce côté
créatif et vous voulez de la bureautique
pur et dur avec de la vraie performance
derrière et bien vous allez sur le
macbook des 16 avec le pavé numérique
sur le côté avec cet écran qui est aussi
très chaud avec du 16/10 ça change donc
c'est super intéressante deux belles
propositions voix ferme il toujours de
très jolies machines donc s'il y en a un
des deux qui vous intéressent une fois
de plus je vous mets le lien en battant
la description pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés à quelque chose près je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous dites moi
ce que vous en pensez en banc
commentaires y en a un qui vous de
bottes vous botte pas vers lequel vous
iriez lequel vous botte le plus épineux
fois de plus j'aimerais qu'on parle d'un
truc intéressant c'est l'écosystème de
huawei avec un smartphone avec les
tablettes avec les écrans avec l'audio
alors que ce soit des anciens que vous
pouvez emmener partout avec vous alors
avec des petits freebox prod2 sont là
plutôt la regarder juste là dites moi ce
que vous en pensez parce que je trouve
ça vachement intéressant cette notion
d'écosystème et de complémentarité entre
les device qui fonctionne très bien
parce que chez huawei ils ont un truc
c'est que en termes de r&d is yvon et sa
cravache donc c'est cool dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en barrant
commentaires on se trouve très vite pour
continuer à parler de textes vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous de vos
besoins beaucoup d'amour du love et
toussa toussa toussa ça c'est chouette
vous embrasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]